so without naming specific campaigns
like what were some of the turn offs and
what were some of the things you said
absolutely i want to do aside from
people playing that whole like oh i know
crowdfunding so hard and you know and it
is there's no doubt about it but when
that's in the video sometimes it is a
turn off but what were some of the
things that you noticed i have to do
this and don't do that
um
well definitely the
the quality of the video i mean everyone
says that
um you know is it framed correctly like
little like filmmaking 101 that a lot of
people
you know here they're asking for money
to make a movie
but their kickstarter video like doesn't
have proper framing
the framing is weird or um
you know they don't have good sound or
good audio
or the edits aren't smooth or they only
have one angle they don't decide to like
cover it from multiple angles
uh stuff like that i would and sort of
a vision like i can i get a sense of
what they're trying to do and why
they build up compelling reasons why i
should
give you know why i should be be part of
it
and i think a lot has to do with sort of
a vision the style of the video i think
that's a big part of it you know
um does it feel like its own little
thing in its own does it have a
beginning a middle and a den you know is
it
you know
do they have a visual sense of being
telling a story because the kickstarter
video is a story you know you're you
know you're telling a story in three
minutes as to who you are what you need
what you've done if they can do that
then and a lot of i see a lot of
kickstarter videos that aren't stories
that aren't they don't they don't have
an arc
and that's what i try to do in my
campaign a little bit and i'm realizing
i
you know could have done things better
but
so in a nutshell then good crowdfunders
script their crowdfunding videos oh i
did i had a whole i scripted mine weeks
in advance man i mean i was like i was
walking in like i was an actor almost
like i'm
you know i mean yeah absolutely i wasn't
going to wing it
and i had actually had a script script
girl on the other side who was helping
me with you know
hey you missed this point or you missed
this and
wow i wasn't i didn't trust myself as
far as making sure because you know you
have like three pages of text to get
through
of dialogue
and and how important was it for you to
make it personal because i like how you
talk about in your kickstarter video
alton illinois and you talk about the
different i think was the world's
tallest man yeah miles davis yeah
exactly so you personalize it you you
let us get to know who you are where
you're from right how important was that
that was extremely important because i
go back to alton i had take a lot of
pride in the community
but i think a big thing was that i'm a
big advocate of midwest filmmakers and
midwest artists and um
and to to say hey i'm from alton you
never heard of alton this is what alton
is known for and i really want the
community of alton to come out and
support the kickstarter campaign
you know
there's thirty thousand people live in
alton and all the peripheral cities east
dalton and bethalto and
godfrey
all these it's the river bend community
and i want to get the riverbend
community behind in the buck
and i'm struggling to do that because
nobody not enough people know about it
so
and i think a lot of it has to do with
the fact that crowdfunding while it's
popular to people
like us who are involved in social media
you go to the middle of america you say
the word kickstarter you know they think
you're talking about a part on a
motorcycle or something they don't they
don't they don't
you know
people that live in la and new york and
even chicago we're all isolated in this
all this social media you know we you
know really we're in a bubble compared
to middle america
um
you know so i think i'm trying to
penetrate that sense of what it means
and they're just not familiar enough so
that's been my major obstacle i think if
i was from a bigger city
it would be different
really so even in 2014 absolutely people
are still not aware of it
no and how do you describe it to them
i say it's a cr i say what what it is is
it's a you have an idea for a project
you make a video and then you ask for a
bunch of different people to come in and
help you get it off the ground
and for kickstarter i say and you set a
goal you know whatever it is it's ten
thousand or a hundred thousand you try
to get all these people to help you and
you you have to hit your goal if you
don't hit your goal then it all goes
away
and you have to like tell it uh very
simply like what do you mean it all goes
away well you don't you don't get any
money it all goes away you know the
project doesn't you have to pitch it as
you know i don't get to do my film or i
don't get to do my project which i'm
going to make my film regardless i'll
make it no matter what but
there's you have to create this sense of
urgency because a lot of people
think that once they press the button
and submit their credit card info that
that money's gone
you know even though it's an all or
nothing thing
so you have to reiterate like it's all
you know don't worry it's
you know uh
then it's all or nothing